hey you guys
here i am once again for my flickers of
fear movie review show
now this movie holy crap i can't believe
it took me this long to see this goddamn
movie
so what ended up happening with this one
for whatever reason
about five or six years ago i mean you
guys know i'm really into
italian jell-o movies and italian horror
in general but a few years back probably
five or six years i kind of went off on
this big long
tear where i was pretty much watching
nothing but that
and that i was doing a bunch of uh you
know reviews of them or writing about
them a lot for my blog
and one evening in particular i just
kind of got this wild hair and i was
sort of like i wonder if anybody
nowadays because i hadn't really kept up
with a lot of newer horror
you know right around the time this came
out i was like i wonder is anybody doing
anything new in that style because that
would be really cool and i would like to
see that
so i looked it up and it turned out that
there had been not a lot but
you know some more modern examples of
giallo or giallo adjacent type of movies
and one of these was called barbarian
sound studio now this came out in 2012.
so i kind of made a list and i wrote it
down and i said oh i'll need to see that
one of these days
and then i guess i kind of you know as
time went on i sort of forgot about it
and then for whatever reason the other
day i was sort of thinking about
uh gala movies or i was thinking about
something like that
and i was like man i should i should see
that because you know i've been wanting
to see it for such a long time and it
sounded really cool like the premise of
it
and it's not exactly a giallo movie but
it's kind of based in that
world you know what i mean which i'll
get to in a minute
so finally i went over to amazon prime
and rented it i believe it was 2 or 3.99
maybe you can get it somewhere else on
another streaming service i'm not really
sure but that's where i got it
and i finally sat down and watch it and
holy crap where has this movie been all
my life i feel like this movie was made
pretty much with my exact demographic in
mind
it's the craziest [ __ ] ever so like i
said this came out back in 2012.
now this is i believe the second film
of uh the british director and
screenwriter
peter strickland i think his first movie
was
a hungarian film i think it was even
hungarian language i haven't seen it but
it got a lot of
notice i guess when it came out but this
was his second one
and this is man this is such a
fascinating premise now i'm gonna say
like this is a psychological horror film
and it's very concerned with
sound and the effect of sound i mean
hence being called barbarian sound
studio
it doesn't show a lot in the sense of
gore a lot of it is like suggestion
and some reviews like most of the
reviews i've seen
have been like really really positive uh
with particular like you know very
famous uh british film reviewer mark
carmod he thought it was uh
i think the best british film of 2012 if
not the best film of 2012 altogether
but i feel like um one kind of divisive
thing is some people didn't really like
the way it ended and i will say that if
you're not
real into surrealism
or if you're gonna be one of those
people that's just like oh my god what
the [ __ ] is going on it's just kind of
gone off the rails or it's being surreal
for the sake of it then probably you
won't like this
uh because it does take a turn uh toward
the third act
but you know me i love that [ __ ] so i
was
i was totally on board even though i'm
not sure
i'm not sure i entirely get it in the
sense that i mean
i don't know the the way that it ends
can be interpreted a lot of different
ways i guess
but you know we'll get into that so this
story is set
sometime in the 60s or 70s it's not
entirely clear and it doesn't really
matter whenever like the heyday of the
italian
giallo movie was so we have this kind of
mousy milk toast english sound engineer
known only as gilderoy and he's played
by toby jones
who is a character actor who has been in
and everything man
like i knew i had seen him in a ton of
[ __ ] and i couldn't remember exactly
what
uh he played truman capote in uh
infamous i think that was kind of his
first breakout role
he was the voice of dobby in the harry
potter movies
um he played a character in some of the
marvel movies
he was in the hunger games he was in w
he was in the mist
he's been in [ __ ] he was in jurassic
world he's just been in a [ __ ]
[ __ ] ton of stuff he was in frost
nixon so yeah if you've seen the dude
you'll recognize him because he's been
in a lot of really big movies
i mean this this is really his movie
because this is a great [ __ ]
performance
so gilderoy is this very you know very
uptight
very kind of mama's boy uh sort of sound
engineer
and he is hired uh to go to italy
and work on a film now his
uh forte i guess uh is sort of like
english nature documentaries very twee
uh and he's doing the sound engineering
so he's very into
listening to the sounds of nature like
recording wind and birds and things like
that
so he gets summoned to italy i guess
because his reputation precedes him or
whatever
um to work on a film that he thinks is a
nature film i guess
about horses it's called because it's
called uh the equestrian vortex
now when he gets there he finds out that
this movie is actually a really really
over-the-top
graphically violent uh jello film
and this really does not sit very well
with him at all
now one of the really interesting things
about this movie is that it's a movie
about making a movie but you never
actually get to see the movie that
they're making
you can hear it because like i said
that's kind of like the whole
that's kind of this whole movie's thing
is the sound design and how
sound and horror kind of go and like it
really the sound that they do like
really kind of
uh you know makes your imagination run
wild or whatever
so i will note too that i love love
i knew i was gonna love this movie like
in the first couple seconds because
instead of having traditional opening
credits
like this movie is called barbarian
sound studio and stars this that and the
other
it actually had opening credits
for the giallo film that is inside the
film the equestrian vortex
and they are spot on i mean so it was
just kind of like this 60s
70s psychedelic satanic kind of [ __ ]
with all this red stuff with all the
all the credits are in italian and stuff
like that i'm like oh movie
uh oh you know what i like so yeah so i
love that they [ __ ] did that and then
they just go into the movie
so over the course of the film he starts
working on this movie he gets there
and after he gets to i mean pretty much
the
whole entire movie takes place inside
this studio you never see the outside i
don't think you ever see the outside
other than one kind of weird like
interstitial where
they show part of a documentary that he
worked on
which was like the english countryside
and stuff but other than that the whole
entire thing is set inside the studio
it's all inside so you never know
whether it's daytime or nighttime so
it's this really creepy like
insular claustrophobic kind of vibe
going on
and it really does well like setting up
this whole sense of dread because
you know here's this very mousy shy
englishman
who gets to this job and
that he thinks is going to be one thing
but then it turns out to be like this
shockingly violent
movie that he's really not comfortable
with doing the sound effects for
and also there's so there's a big
culture clash
he doesn't speak italian some of the
other people speak english but some of
them don't
and everyone seems vaguely not
not hostile necessarily but they're just
kind of you know he he doesn't really
relate to them in the same way that he
would relate to somebody from his own
country perhaps
uh they just seem very kind of brusque
and uh
you know and kind of rude even though
from their point of view they're not
being rude and they're always kind of
like over the top and boisterous and he
just can't
you know get with it and also you're
kind of like
even from the beginning you're not
entirely sure i mean you know that
probably something sinister is going on
but you're not entirely sure what it is
which i think is like really good
because
it just has this really creepy like what
the [ __ ] is happening with this [ __ ]
so most of the movie is him
kind of getting increasingly disturbed
by this movie that they're making
because and like i said they never show
the actual movie the equestrian vortex
other than the opening credits like at
the very beginning
but you know the the film is always kind
of going and then you see the people
reacting to it and then you see
all the people that are coming in doing
the sound effects on it so they have
like all these women coming in
doing the overdubbing um you know all
these women coming in
screaming them doing like the music them
doing fully so like they'll bring in all
these
vegetables and stuff and like chop them
up or throw them on the phone like for
people getting chopped up and stabbed
and
falling out falling onto the concrete
and you know that kind of stuff which is
great
so you can kind of imagine what's going
on in the movie
even though you can't see it because you
can see like his increasingly horrified
reactions to it
so that kind of goes on but then uh and
this is gonna be
a bit spoilery i think although like i
said i don't know
this is one of those movies where i
don't think it really matters if it's
spoiled or not because
the whole thing is just so concerned
with the atmosphere that it builds and
like just the weirdness surrounding it
that it's not like you know it's not
like a straightforward narrative story
so it's not like oh big plot twist and
you spoiled it blah blah
but so right about two-thirds of the way
through the movie
you start to think that maybe everything
is not as it seems because up to this
point everything seems pretty
straightforward
you know you're kind of uncomfortable
with this character because he's like
everyone seems
kind of cranky towards him or seems like
they have their own agendas and you're
not really sure what they are
and he's just doesn't want to work on
this movie anymore because he finds it
revolting and disgusting and violent you
know the the director of the movie whose
name is santini who shows up later
he keeps trying to deny that it's a
horror film it's like no i'm just
showing what's true man it's a
the movie is essentially like it's like
suspiria
like in the sense that it's about
witches but it's also about like people
torturing witches so you know it's kind
of that type of thing
and so a lot of the things that you hear
are you know people being tortured or
sound effects of being tortured
but then uh there's kind of a recurring
thing through
throughout the uh the movie where
gilderoy
keeps wanting to be uh reimbursed for
his flight
to italy because they said they would
reimburse him because obviously he's
coming there for a job
and every time he tries to get the money
you know people keep pawning him off
it's like oh that's not my department or
why don't you go ask so and so like they
actually act like they don't really care
and then like the director's like what
you don't trust us you think we're not
going to pay you and he gets like kind
of hostile about it
and then finally like this other woman
that's been working on the movie
like as one of the uh overdubbing
actresses and the one that's been
screaming and stuff in the booth
she says to him she's like you know
these type of people you just have to go
in and like demand what you want they
don't
you can't just ask them you can't just
say oh hey can you check on that you
have to go in there and go give me this
right now and you have to do that kind
of stuff
so he goes and he starts like kind of
throwing his weight around
so he does that and people seem to
respond well to it but then it turns
out that they said well we can't they
call around and they try to check and
they're like we can't reimburse you for
your uh for your ticket for the flight
because that flight doesn't exist and
at this point things go real
inland empire uh in the sense that i
mean not quite that
out there which is a david lynch movie
if you haven't seen it
not quite that out there but reality
and the movie that they're making start
to blend together
after that revelation that this flight
did
like apparently never occurred uh so
they can't pay him for it
then [ __ ] starts to get weird
like he starts to have dreams where
he walks out of his room or the
apartment that he's staying in
and then he's back in the studio then he
sees
movies of himself up on the thing like
doing
[ __ ] that he just did then the movie
goes in a direction where it kind of
starts over again from earlier scenes
but now
he's dubbed into italian as though he's
in the movie
so it's almost kind of like you're not
really sure where
the reality of this movie in the movie
are and then you're kind of thinking
like he gets these has these couple of
letters from his mom
uh you know because he lived with his
mom back in england he's from dorking
i love that which is a real place in
case you didn't because i remember
seeing the signs for that over there i'm
like oh man
that's unfortunate but yeah so uh so
he's from dorking
and uh so he had some letters from his
mom and his mom was talking about oh
these birds that had nested there and
then like the
the letters get increasingly horrific
like
some some magpies came and killed all
the birds and tore their heads off and
there's blood everywhere and all this
other stuff
but then like later they have to bring
in like
like one of the actresses gets pissed
off at the director
and destroys like all of the [ __ ] that
she recorded so they have to bring in
somebody else to re-record her stuff
and that person starts reciting stuff
from
gilderoy's mom's letters so it just goes
real real weird so you're not really
sure
if he's a real person or
i don't know it's so so it's just kind
of like so keep in mind that it's that
kind of thing so it gets like real
surreal toward the end where
reality and the movie that they're
making are overlapping and you're not
entirely sure if he's a real person
or if he's just a character in this
movie so it's like a movie within a
movie like a
mobius strip type of uh deal like i said
it kind of reminded me
of uh inland empire in that way also
gonna say
gave me some video drone vibes a little
bit
a little bit like peeping tom uh that
type of [ __ ]
maybe it looks like maybe some polanski
movies
um some people have compared it to the
conversation with uh gene hackman
so or maybe like a blow up kind of like
that too
so if that sounds like something like i
said this is not
it's based on you know the back story of
it is like giallo
and there's little nods in there to like
you know the dude that
runs one of the uh machines is like
wearing a black glove and there's
there's like little easter eggs in there
for people that are into jello movies
and like i said that opening credits
scene is just
i knew i was gonna love the movie as
soon as i saw that because i was like oh
my god that's fantastic
but this in itself is not a jello movie
it's more like a surrealist
psychological horror that's based in
that world
but that said i mean it's just
it's so weird and it's just so so good
and it's like i can't believe that i
took
this long to [ __ ] see it it's just
amazing
and i will note too that because sound
is pretty much
i mean very very much to the forefront
in this movie it's kind of like the
the main character really is all the
screams and the sound effects and
just all the sound design the sound
design is fantastic so i would actually
recommend that you
if you watch it like kind of watch it in
a quiet environment
and on a really good sound system so you
can kind of appreciate like all the
all the score and all the stuff that's
going on because it's really it's it's
really amazing
you know again not a traditional horror
movie but if you like giallo films if
you like surrealist type of films
anything like david lynch or
you know like i said kind of
cronenbergian anything kind of like that
it's not bloody there's not like you
know it's not big murders or anything
like that you don't really see anything
gory but it's just a real weird creepy
you know just kind of dread inducing
psychological horror with a really
interesting you know with with the
giallo tinge and with
you know said in an interesting setting
that you don't see a lot in horror
movies
so yeah um definitely check it out like
i said i rented it on amazon prime i
think it was 299 or 3.99 or something
like that if you're in another country i
don't know it might be on another
streaming service because it's a british
film
uh so i checked uk shutter and i didn't
see it on there so i don't know where
you guys can get it but i'm sure you can
get it somewhere else uh easily if it
sounds like your kind of thing
but yeah i really dug it and uh if you
like that kind of stuff then i pro then
i think you probably will too
but let me know in the comments if you
saw it and what you thought of it
and that will do it for this flickers of
fear i will see you guys on the next one
bye